a picture has leaked from last week's
major world powers meeting in Germany
the g20 where Ivanka Trump the unelected
daughter of the president was seen
sitting in the United States chair next
to other world leaders instead of the
actual president of the United States
here is a picture that leaked of Ivanka
Trump sitting next to British prime
minister Theresa May
German Chancellor and the new leader of
the free world Angela Merkel and China's
Chinese President Xi Jinping Donald
Trump of course talking about just how
great it was that Ivanka Trump was able
to do this very proud of my daughter
Ivanka always happened from day one I
have to tell you that from day one she's
always been great champion she can't she
weren't my daughter would be so much
easier for her might be the only bad
thing she has going if you want to know
the truth according to the AFP the White
House later said Ivanka quote briefly
joined the main table when the president
had to step out it doesn't matter
whether it was briefed or not or what
the reason was
Ivanka Trump is not a representative of
the American people if someone needs to
step in for the president put in some
kind of government official our depraved
Russia connected Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson for example imagine for one
second if Hillary Clinton were president
and had Chelsea CID in for a little
while at the g20 there is no scenario
where Republicans look the other way if
Hillary Clinton is tired or has to step
out or whatever doesn't show up and her
daughter who was not elected by the
American people to represent them and
would actually be forbidden from working
for her because of nepotism laws sits in
at a meeting this is an unelected person
connected to the president only by
virtue of being their kid and she sat on
the world stage as the representative of
the United States of America and what
Trump was getting at in that video - was
that Ivanka wouldn't say scrutiny had
she not been Trump's daughter but she
wouldn't even be in that room if it
wasn't for Trump's daughter I mean maybe
she may have still had a successful
fashion career maybe write it she may
have been a self-made person regardless
of if she was born to Donald Trump or
not but that wouldn't put her in the
room with all those world leaders at the
g20 summit that's right she's right that
if she weren't his daughter she would
not be suffering scrutiny because she
wouldn't be in the room and by the way
Ivanka has told us that she tries to
stay out of politics many times here's
just one example of that you know I try
to stay out of politics mm-hmm you know
I I make it very clear where I stand on
a certain issue tough to stay away
apparently how is Ivanka even there
right I mean because of the
anti-nepotism laws how is she even able
to be there well she is an unpaid
advisor with no official role skirting
the letter of the ethical restrictions
of nepotism laws and this entire thing
of well Trump has separated from his
businesses not really
Ivanka Trump is an unpaid advisor she
has no such restrictions she's advising
Trump and working on the businesses as
much as she wants
or at least fully aware of what's going
on with the businesses Trump is running
the country like a business right this
is what he did in business you get his
kids he got his kids to do the work as
needed this is the type of thing you see
and expect in less developed nations not
what we should expect from the United
States and I'm getting emails Pat from
lower level elected officials from
Europe from the European Union who
watched the show and they're saying if
this happened in our countries you would
see dismissal from government taking
place it's just not taking being taken
seriously in the United States and
there's basically two paths forward
right either this presidency ends up
being seen as a sort of aberration in
every way when it's looked back at from
the future an outlier it was a terrible
idea and it's something that we've
learned our lesson on and will never
repeat or the Trump presidency might
normalize this and we will end up seeing
a series of Trump like totally abortive
elected officials and I'm worried it's
going to be the latter because we're
seeing very little in the way of
repercussions for Trump right now and
sure Ivanka Trump was technically
allowed to sit in for the president at
that
time because she was part of his party
is delegation there at the meeting but
she should not have been there in the
first place and I think that's the
greater point it is a laughingstock it
is a total and utter laughingstock and
the world is laughing quite literally
talk about this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit we'll be back today's
program made possible in part by
movement watches movement watches has a
cool backstory which is not that
different from the David Pakman show
sister II they were started by two broke
college kids who wanted stylish watches
they would go in to big department
stores and they'd see price tags of four
five and six hundred dollars on the
watches that they liked so instead they
did a crowdfunding campaign much like
the david pakman show has done at
different points in our history they
completely cut out the middleman and
just as importantly the retail markup
that exists on many watches and they now
provide really great looking watches for
as little as ninety five dollars I have
to movement watches this being one of
them with the white face everywhere I go
people say that's a really good watch
the other day I checked in at my
dentist's office and they look at me and
they said what kind of a watch is that I
really like that and I notice when I'm
talking to friends I'll just be talking
and gesticulated as I tend to do and
they're focused on the watch rather than
my face which is not great for our
conversation but apparently it's good
for movement watches you can get a
movement watch with a 15% discount free
shipping and free returns in case it's
not right for you by going to M V M
t.com forward slash Pakman 15% off free
shipping free returns
MVM t-dot-com slash PA k ma n